do you ever feel like sometimes nothing
seems to be going right and then your
one friend who is super into astrology
explains that mercury is in retrograde
the first thing we need to clear up is
that mercury is not in retrograde
mercury is just retrograde this is the
astronomical phenomenon when a planet
appears to be moving backwards reversing
its orbit from our point of view here on
earth it's actually an optical illusion
you see planets orbit the Sun at
different speeds and retrograde occurs
generally as a faster moving planet
catches up with and then passes a slower
moving planet other planets retrograde -
but because mercury is the fastest
planet in the solar system it
retrogrades more frequently about three
to four times a year and lasts for about
two to three weeks ancient Romans and
Greeks personified the planet Mercury as
the messenger deity
similarly in astrology mercury rules
over communication it also governs
analytical thinking expression of ideas
and the processing of information so in
astrology when mercury retrogrades all
those things get kind of scrambled hence
why some people feel uh Teran total
chaos during this period different
Mercury retrograde can have different
effects on us depending on which sign
it's moving through and they can take on
more of the qualities of that sign for
instance the sign cancer is associated
with home and family as well as
emotional intensity a Mercury retrograde
through cancer could have us focus on
aspects of our family and home life and
get deeper in touch with our emotional
state in 2018 all Mercury retrograde
will pass through fire signs Aries Leo
and Sagittarius therefore we may be more
willing than normal to engage in
conflict over things we're passionate
about because that's what fire signs do
well there is generally a negative
connotation surrounding retrograde
periods there are also ways to interpret
mercury retrograde that are more
positive since things will feel a little
crazy during retrograde it can be a good
opportunity to do some internal
reflecting rather than making impulsive
decisions this can give you a chance to
reassess your desires and purpose so now
you know everything you need to know
about Mercury retrograde have fun using
it as
excuse for all of your problems
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part